well disgraced prince angel will
reportedly appear next to the queen and
one of the most important royal
ceremonies in the calendar the garter
day at windsor castle in june of course
it's the queen's decision but it won't
be a popular one in april 2021 andrew
shocked us all by giving interviews to
the press before his father's funeral
despite being accused of sexual assault
in march he took center stage by walking
the queen into westminster abbey for
phillips memorial service and next week
he's set to step into the spotlight
again when he appears in his garter
robes so is prince andrew trying to
weasel his way back into the royal
family in public i'm joined by the royal
to the vanity fair katie nicholl and
royal author and british social lady
colin campbell welcome to both of you
katie
this does great with me i have to say i
think if you're going to pay
a woman
a rumored 11 million dollars to make a
sex abuse case go away having said
you're going to fight it all the way to
clear your name and then he just caved
yeah i don't think you're entitled to
just slither back into public life in a
few months i agree with you i think it's
time for him to go away actually um in
the same way that that settlement just
sort of struck it all out
the the dignified and actually the
respectful thing to do for the queen and
for the royal family is to bow out
gracefully as gracefully as he possibly
can this has been a spectacular fall
from angie he doesn't have his title
doesn't have his honorary titles doesn't
represent the queen doesn't carry out
official duties um i think it's very
difficult then to reconcile seeing him
on a public stage i know these events
essentially can be seen as private
events the garter is privately bestowed
it's the highest the queen can give okay
and this is an important one because
let's not forget she's investing camilla
and tony blair i think so yeah okay less
on that but more importantly on camilla
um this is once again going to detract
from all of this and i think that just a
lot of people will be sitting and
watching and thinking why and i know
from the american audience that i write
for every time the queen is seen with
andrew
it it it troubles them it does well also
they also think quite rightly um that
i'll come to bloody colin campbell now
uh first of all uh good evening to you
thank you for joining the show i i you
know i do think that for example
we give you know megan and harry a hard
time i think justifiably in most cases
um but this what they've done to be
honest pales into insignificance in my
opinion to a senior member of the royal
family paying millions of dollars to
make a sex abuse case go away
but you don't share this do you think
you should be able to come back
i certainly don't share this view first
of all my information was that its five
figures was the settlement and also each
party had to pay its own costs and
expenses i know the press keeps on going
on and on banging the drum about several
million pounds and million dollars i
don't know where they got it from
because this it's the settlement was
supposed to be confidential
so uh
how do you know it's not it's not
believable as your 10 or 20 figures well
how do you how do you know it's not if
it's confidential
well
how do my point is how do you know that
it's 11 million dollars no it's been
reported it's been reported from very
it's been reported from very good
sources it was 11 million dollars if
you're saying it was a a a much smaller
sum i'm just curious how you reported
from very good sources i was i was told
from from very good sources that it was
a five-figure sum that's not true i can
tell you i know categorically that's not
true
well you you mean you know categorically
that i know 100 of what you've just said
is not true it's not a five-figure
settlement i know that for a fact well i
know categorically that's what i was
told and i believe my source is rather
more than yours okay well you don't know
who my source is but if you did you
wouldn't say that but let's move on to
the wider point
whether you're
look whether it's five figures or
millions or whatever it finally was he
settled the case having said he was
going to fight it to clear his name and
i think if you do that as a senior
member of the royal family you should
not be allowed to continue in public
life
utter rubbish parents with due respect i
mean since when
was this a country where you are guilty
until proven innocent this may play very
well in the court of popular
uh condemnation but the reality is in
this country as in all civilized
countries you are innocent until you are
proven guilty why didn't he clear his
name he kept saying he kept saying i'm
going to clear my name
why didn't he clear his name
why didn't he get a call why didn't she
she kept on she kept on saying she kept
on saying that she would never settle
uh that she wanted her day in court she
is an admitted procureus prostitute no
no you're making allegations now which
are unsubstantiated and i have to make
that on the record
i'm sorry they are they are
unsubstantiated allegations and nothing
that you're saying to she has admitted
nothing you're saying to attack nothing
nothing you're saying to attack the
accuser lady colin will change the fact
that prince andrew who's nearly 30 years
her senior that he publicly declared
just a few months before the settlement
i will not settle this case i will have
had my day in court i will clear my name
and then he settled with him she did the
same thing and she settled he's a senior
member of the royal family and she said
he was the one accused of sexual assault
of a of in america a minor and he
settled that case without clearing him
you say
how do we know he's interested
for sexual purposes in either england or
the united states of america the states
that were concerned she was over the age
of consent you know pairs rarely you sh
i mean that's not true
i'm sorry that's not that's actually not
true she was under the age of one is not
she was considered a legal minor in at
least one of the american locations
where the sex was alleged to have
happened but my point is you say andrew
was not so
that is so actually the state that
that's not so because the state of of
new york is is 16 years old or 17 and in
england it is over
she was 17 years old so i'm sorry that's
absolute rubbish no it's not
relationship over the age okay sexual i
don't think you understand the the both
you don't understand the law of of
consent age of consent in american
states it's fine let's come back to you
on this i mean look emotions run high
about this kind of thing
and the bottom line for me is andrew
decided to settle it okay so when
someone settles it and doesn't have
their day in court having promised to to
me it's like you're not even proving
you're innocent no you've just paid off
the case absolutely but i think also you
know if i can just move the conversation
on a little bit from this the there is
an underlying issue here and i think
what this exposes is that difficult
situation that the queen is in as
monarch and as a mother i agree
i remember i was told by very close sort
of the queen that she had challenged
andrew asked him if he was innocent and
he told her repeatedly that he was now
she clearly believes him yeah and she
stand and as lady c says in fairness
innocent till provenance we don't know
he's guilty we just know he didn't go
and have his day in court absolutely but
putting that aside the problem is i go
back to this is is the optics and for
someone who has settled out of court and
all the sort of murky image of that
really at a time when we're wanting to
see the royal family united and at its
best behind the queen do we need andrew
tagging along as i say the graceful
thing would have been to exited quietly
he's not serving any purpose other than
to detract and make headlines in my
opinion they're all the wrong and also
on the guard today being seen as a royal
knight in all the regalia really
that day honors chivalry i mean are we
really going to be having andrew and
this is parading around in his gown
honoring chivalry wearing this kind of
clothing this is the problem
a sex abuse case anyway look go leave it
there katie thank you lady colin thank
you feisty as always appreciate you
joining me
my pleasure if pleasure's the right word
you look like you almost meant it as
well